Hey guys, so you guys are asking questions about how to know where to set up your daily
budget.
So I'm going to go through one of the ads that we have set up here.
This is for a patio cover and we're going to just kind of show you how we set that up.
So the big thing that we use to set that up as we go through the training is what your
CPC is and bidding your CPC using tools like the Keyword Planner here is where we go and
we learn how much the keywords are going to be and that will typically set us up for what
our daily budget will be.
When you go and you set up your ad and you set up your daily budget, you will have like
right here we set up our daily budget of $45 a day and that was based on what our CPC was
going to be and what we wanted to do for that area.
So you can see here that this gives me a bunch of different options which anywhere from $23.26
all the way up to $292 a day and it will give you how many clicks to expect and the cost,
the impressions and how much to get to the top impression.
So that is one way to look at it.
We try to keep it between typically between $25 to $35 a day.
This area is San Antonio, Texas so it's a little bit more but you can see here that
we've been getting good results at $45 a day for our client and you can see here that Google
is wanting to push us all the way up to $300 a day.
So that's just where you need to apply that.